okay let's get started
welcome back everyone trey will continue
into lecture eight
is that right yes lecture eight
so the topics for today will be kernel
methods and support vector machines
and before we jump into uh today's
topics
let's do a quick recap of what we
covered in the previous lecture
we covered generative algorithms um
in generative algorithms
for training we maximize the joint
probability of p
of um or the joint likelihood p of x
comma y where x is your input and y is
the
output and we we train the parameters
using mle
and this is generally decomposed into
two parts the class prior
and p of x given y and at prediction
time we use bayes rule to construct the
posterior distribution of p of y given x
right and the posterior will will be
different for different models
depending on what assumptions we make of
whether p of x given y is gaussian or
bernoulli or
or whatever you find we find a p of y
given x accordingly
right and we saw two examples of ah two
different types of
generative models the gaussian
discriminant analysis and
naive bayes so in gaussian discrete
analysis
x is continuous the inputs are
continuous
and we make the assumption that p of x
given y
follows a normal distribution with the
mean that is specific to y
and some shared covariance sigma
and the uh the corresponding posterior
for prediction time
follows a logistic
logistic regression um functional form
right and um you have more details of
this in your first homework and
um hopefully that's that's uh clear
next we saw naive bayes ah here x was
discrete
like words in a text message um
and we we made this crucial
conditional independence assumption so
to remind you conditional independence
means
p of x j given y and x k is equal to p
of x j given y right and conditional
independence
is very different from general
right if two variables are conditionally
independent it says nothing about
whether they are
independent or not and similarly if two
variant two uh variables are independent
it says nothing about whether they are
conditionally independent or not um
and then with the with using this
conditional independence assumption
we constructed two different event
models in
one of uh the first event model that we
saw was called the bernoulli event model
where
p of x j given y follows a bernoulli
distribution
and here x j refers to the jth word in
our vocabulary or our dictionary
and we saw another model called the
multinomial event model where p of x j
given phi
follows a multinomial distribution but
crucially x j over here refers to the j
word in a message
here x j refer to the j word in the
vocabulary
right and the general intuition behind
these two is that
in the bernoulli event model ah suppose
we applied for say spam classification
the spamminess of a word is determined
by
how many messages the word appears in
and how many message
how in what fraction of the spam
messages the word occurs in
what fraction of the non-spam message of
the word occurs in
whereas in the multinomial model the
spamminess of a word
is determined by what fraction of
all the words in the spammy messages is
this word
and what fraction of all the words in
the non-spammy messages
is this word by not caring about the
message boundaries
right we consider just the set of all
the
the collection of all words across all
messages and
just construct a multinomial
distribution of all the words
right and then we also covered laplace
smoothing where the idea of laplace
smoothing is
we don't want to be severely swayed by
rare words so words that probably never
occurred in our training
training training data set we still want
to do something
meaningful in at prediction time and the
idea there is
we perform something called laplace
smoothing where
we assume we've seen say every word
or we assume that you know we see one
example of each class
once in in our training set and then we
start look at
at the training data and do our you know
counting of
messages or counting over words or so on
right that's
uh that's a quick recap of what we did
any questions on this before we move on
to the rest topic yes
so the question is are there any
conditions on the prior that
uh that will make the uh posterior take
a logistic form so that's a good
question so
in general uh if
if we are having
a binary class where y is 0 or 1
right and x given y takes a form
any form in the exponential family the
posterior will always be a logistic
form right similarly if your y
is a categorical so one among many
and x given y belongs to any
distribution in the exponential family
then your y given x will take the soft
max form
that's that's that's a common um um
that's a property that holds for all
exponential family distributions
uh with either
a bernoulli prior or a categorical prior
good question
yeah for uh for the logistic x cube and
y needs to be in the exponential family
good question any other questions before
we move on to
kernel methods ok so let us move on to
kernel methods
so i'm going to start off yes question
so the question is you know why do we
want to use um
the generative model in place of say
logistic regression for
uh if if you know the at prediction time
if it takes a logistic education form
why not just take you know uh um
do logistic regression itself and i
think we touched upon this
um in in the last class so in situations
where
you don't have a lot of data and you
know that your x is distributed
according to gda
then using gda
you're going to have you uh is going to
be more efficient
by efficient i mean sample efficient you
can you can achieve higher accuracy or
you know your model
works better with fewer amount of data
if
the modeling assumptions hold true if
your x given y actually
follows gaussian right whereas if
a logistic regression in general is more
robust even if
these assumptions are violated logistic
regression tends to just work well
but in those cases where the assumptions
hold true
then gda is more sample efficient with
fewer number of examples you get a
better model
right so kernel methods so um
so far in the class all the models that
we have seen have been linear models
right they are they are linear in x
and the
for example linear regression gives you
a linear hypothesis in x
and logistic regression gives you a
linear classifying boundary
in your data space however
as you've probably seen in your homework
one question five i think
you can actually start constructing
non-linear hypothesis using linear
regression
right and similarly you we can also
construct
non-linear classifiers using logistic
regression
by including higher order features
for example if you if
your x if you map it to some
phi of x where phi of x is
1 x x square you know
x to the
for right and now if you perform
linear regression on this feature vector
rather than performing linear regression
directly on
x the ah the linear regression will give
you
a non-linear hypothesis right
this is x your ah the linear regression
will give your hypothesis that might
look like this and and this is ah
this is because we have included higher
order polynomial terms
now to ah
extend this into the classification
setting similarly
rights ah suppose this is x one
x d in this case it was x
and y so supposing you may have
two classes
right now if you fit a linear regression
for example you might get
a separating hyperplane like this
but what if um um in in
in case of ah logistic regression our
data was
something like this
right in such cases we could have ah
just as in the case of linear regression
we could have included a few uh say
quadratic features and we would have
gotten
a separating boundary that looks like
this even though it was we are
performing logistic regression because
we have mapped our
data into a higher dimensional feature
space
right now this seemed
a little arbitrary
for example how many features do we map
it to
in this case we mapped a one dimensional
feature to
five dimensions why not map it to ten
dimensions
right what's the right answer why not
map it to a thousand dimensions
right or even why not map it to an
infinite number of dimensions
right it's hard to think of infinite
dimensional feature vectors
you cannot even represent it explicitly
on a computer
but we will see that with kernel methods
we can actually do such things of
taking an example and mapping it to an
in
potentially infinite dimensional feature
vector
and perform our learning algorithm in
that
infinite dimensional space right
so the
in terms of terminology
the given x we will call it
attributes
right and phi of x which is the set of
features we will call this
features
right and in cases when there are no
feature maps
it is common to call xs features itself
you know just just
think your feature map is an identity
function
right and let us start with
a motivating example of linear
regression
of how we solve linear regression using
gradient descent
right in linear regression for gradient
design we
the update rule we had was theta
t plus one equals
theta t plus
alpha some learning rate times
i equals 1 to n
y i minus
h theta of x i in linear regression this
was theta transpose
x i times
x i right this was the update rule for
linear regression using gradient descent
and we run this over and over
until the model converges which means
our theta vector stops
stops changing a lot right now
if we were to use a feature map like
this
so with a feature map
we get the rule theta t plus 1
equals theta t
plus alpha times
i equals 1 to n
y i minus theta transpose phi of x
i times
v of x i
right so we just replaced x with phi of
x
right and we are performing gradient
descent on this on this uh
feature map the difference between these
two equations is
over here theta is in
[Music]
r d and over here theta is in
r p assuming our phi
takes you from r d to
r p the idea here is d is the dimension
of your original data
and p is some high dimensional space
potentially infinite right
so um
so this is the update rule that we get
and now ah imagine our
feed to be um
a feature map like this like v of x
equals this just one example right
one x 1
x 2 and all the
then x 1 square x 1
x 2 x 1 x 3
and so on so let me x 1 cube
x 1 square x 2
and so on right so basically
a set of all monomial terms
of order less than equal to three
right now what we see is ah
the number of the dimension of the
feature vector in this case
will be p will be approximately
already cube right
it's going to be cubic times for all the
three order terms and some
two order terms one order term but
overall it's going to be you know the
cubic term is going to dominate and
it's going to be approximately d cube
number of
uh features which means um
to perform each gradient
descent update we now move from
calculating dot products in
d dimension for example if d was a
thousand
d was thousand right this dot product
would take about ah
order d ah order d
right whereas this dot product is going
to take about
order d q so which means if if you had d
equals to a thousand
this would take about say a thousand
time steps whereas
this would take about 1000 q would be
like a billion time steps
right so potentially each performing
each update rule can be a million times
slower and
that expense is mostly because we cho we
just happen to choose a higher
dimensional
feature space right
now let us make a few observations
so the claim here is that if we
in linear regression if we were to start
with theta naught equal to the zero
vector
if we start with the zero vector as our
initial
starting point if gradient descent is
started from there then the claim is
that
any theta vector
theta t can be represented as
1 to n beta
i v of
x i right so the claim is
input
the theta t that we encounter during any
state
any stage of our gradient descent
can always be represented as a linear
combination
of the features right and this should be
obvious
because assume theta
0 is is just 0 then theta 1 will be
each of this is a scalar a scalar times
phi of x i and it's it's the sum over
them and you can you can absorb the
alpha inside and alpha times
y i minus theta t of phi of x i will be
and theta at 0 will be just 0 so
the
theta of 1 will be
i equals 1 to n
alpha times
y i times phi
of x i
right so the very first theta vector
that we get
after the first step is going to be a
linear combination
of the feature vectors
right and the and this will hold on
this will hold at every state every
stage of gradient descent right
the next ah for example now we can show
by induction
that
let me start on the freshwater
theta t plus 1
equals theta plus
t plus alpha
n y
i minus theta
t transpose
v of x i
times phi
x i and we can just expand
this so theta t
by induction we can ah write it as a
linear combination of
beta i of
t times
v of x i
so this is this
plus right here alpha times
i equals 1 to n
y i minus again we are going to
expand this with this
equals 1 to n
beta i of t
times phi of
x i so
this is theta transpose
fee of
x i
times v of
x i right
maybe i can use a few different colors
to um
i like this so um
what we did is
this is
theta theta t and
this is the other theta t
right
did i miss something yeah and
this thing over here
is now essentially our
right before we do
and this i am going to rewrite this as
i equals 1 to n
beta i of
t plus so basically i'm taking the uh
a common sum across across both the
terms
beta i plus
alpha times
y i minus
i equals 1 j equals 1 to n
beta j times v
x j transpose
v of x
i
p of x j transpose
i'm going to use a different color
times v of
x i right
so ah what we see is that now
theta of t plus one can be represented
as
again a linear combination of e i's
where each of these
is beta t plus one
of i what what what what happened just
here just now so we started with the
with the usual gradient descent update
rule of theta t
plus 1 is theta t plus you know
plus the gradient and then
to show by induction that theta t plus
one can be
represented as a linear combination of
our feature vectors
we uh we use the uh inductive assumption
that
theta t can now be written as a linear
combination of our feature vectors
so we plug plugged in
so we plugged in that expansion here and
similarly we plugged in that expansion
here
and basically just reorganize the sums
right
and we get that theta t plus one can now
also
be written as a linear combination of
our feature vectors where the
new coefficients for performing the
linear combination
are these terms yes questions
so so the question is in the higher
dimensional feature space
the features are not independent
and but that's fine because we made no
independence assumptions about
um about the features being independent
for gradient descent
yeah the update is the same exactly so
we don't care about what the features
are we just perform
well so the feature so for linear
regression to work um
the features should ideally not be
linearly dependent in this case they are
not linearly dependent
right there they are somewhat dependent
but it's not that one of them is a
linear combination of the other
right so this is um so with this
observation we get the update rule
in terms of betas
let me go with this one more time just
because this is
this is a probably the most crucial part
for to understanding kernel methods
right so we started with the theta
vectors
right we're performing gradient descent
over theta vectors
on the parameter space and this is the
update rule that we have
right and we saw that theta 1
over here
theta 1 is trivially a linear
combination of your features
based on this rule where theta 0 is 0 so
this term cancels out
and you get theta 1 equals 0 plus alpha
you know sum over
i from 1 to n alpha times y i times
feature
of x i so theta 1 is trivially a linear
combination of our features
right all good so that kind of
bootstraps our inductive argument
and for the inductive step we assume
theta t
is
is already a linear combination of our
features
and the the the beta i's are the
coefficients which make up the linear
combination for theta uh for theta t
and now theta t plus 1 is
into this expression you know expand out
theta t in terms of the
linear weights of phi of x i right
so in this place we plug in the expanded
linear combination of p of x i and in
this place
we plug in the linear combination of
feature of x i
and then just do some algebra move
things around and we're going to get it
in the form where theta t plus 1
is still a linear combination of
features of x
i where the next set of coefficients are
calculated this way
right so that completes our inductive
proof that
in case of linear regression your the
theta vectors
at any stage during gradient descent can
always be represented
as a linear combination of our features
right
any questions in this yes
yeah this this is yeah you're right so
this should be j
yeah thank you
yes questions
so this one was was so
i took this summation and this summation
this summation and this
summation common outside so it just
appears just once here
right so so this summation is is is
common for
this term and this term so i've taken
that out
does this make sense or
did i misunderstand your question
so uh right so um
for each so uh there is one summation
over here and beta i appears once
per summation and over here it appears
once per summation
right and over here there are you know
two nested summations so
here's the outer summation and here's
the inner summation for this meter
yeah that's the inner summation right
right so now we ah
we can write this as
you know ah we can write the same
same thing right like this
beta t plus 1
i is equal to
beta t of i
plus alpha times
y i minus
j equals 1 through n
beta j of t
times v of
x j
transpose phi of
x i okay so basically
just plug this here where now
the next the the beta coefficient the
ith beta coefficient at time t
plus 1 is equal to
this over here right and this we do it
for
i equals one through n
and we repeat this over and over
until we converge in our beta values
right so this is basically gradient
descent
written in terms of theta space
and this is the same gradient descent
written
as coefficients of the feature vector
right so ah a few things we can notice
ah right away is that
at first it might appear for each
iteration
for each of the example we are summing
over
we are we are doing a dot product
between two high dimensional
feature vectors at each iteration for
each example
right but however the dot product
between all the
high level features can be pre-computed
because the examples are not changing
iteration to iteration
right so we can pre-compute the dot
product between
every pair of examples in their high
dimensional feature space
and just use the precomputed values in
each iteration
right so this is not changing example to
example the only thing that's changing
is are the betas
right and so the betas are changing
iteration to iteration the feature maps
are constant so we can pre-compute them
and
use them so this thing evaluates to some
scalar right so you can pre compute a
big matrix of scalars
yes question
so this is x j and this is x i
right however now the question is now
what if this is infinite dimensional
right we got we got a way in which we
can now represent
our parameters um
using by replacing our parameters with
coefficients
because theta in a high dimensional
feature space theta would also
have been high dimensional right so we
got a way around
representing a very high dimensional
parameter vector
with a set of coefficients where the
coefficients
have are are you have as many
coefficients as the number of examples
which is
always finite however we still have
a dot product between potentially two
infinite dimensional
feature vectors right and that's where
the
concept of a kernel comes into picture
right so kernel is defined as
so a kernel is some function
k that maps
i'm going to write
2 so script x represents the space
where ah the space where x is reside
in this case it is you know um in our
case
x is in rd which means
script x equals rd
so it takes two examples and maps it to
a real number right so this is
the definition of a kernel and
it does it in such a way such that it
satisfies
k of x comma z
is equal to
the inner product between phi of x
comma v of z
where phi is some feature vector
right so the kernel corresponding to a
feature vector phi
is defined as a function
where the value of the function is equal
to
the inner product between the feature
map of x
dot product with the feature map of c so
this is the same as
v of x transpose p of z
right yes question
can you can you please repeat the
question
this line
the line above it
rd so so this is this is defining the
space
so x is in script x
right so in this case the script x
happens to be r d but in general
you know this need not be in rd it could
even be
like strings the set of all strings or
set of all graphs right it's
it's an abstract space um
and a kernel is a function which takes
two elements of that space and returns a
real valued
ah a real valued scalar
and it also satisfies
the property that the evaluated value
can be expressed
as the inner product between two feature
maps
or between
between the the feature map of input one
dot product with the feature map of
input two
right and for the example that we saw
here
okay so for the example where phi of
x is equal to the set of all monomials
up to order three x x one x 2
etcetera x 1 cube right
where
so this feature feature vector
has a corresponding kernel so k of
x comma z
is equal to 1 plus
inner product of x comma z
plus inner product of x comma
z square plus
inner product of x comma
z cube right
is this it is exactly the same as
v of transpose
v of c so this is one example of a
kernel
right where for this particular feature
map which had
you know if if x was in
rd then p
is approximately order dq
right and in order to perform an inner
product
or the dot product in this high
dimensional feature space
would require order d cube number of
operations
right whereas over here in the kernel
form
we see that this takes order d
this takes order d and this takes
order d right and you sum over
three such order d operations and you
are still in already
right so this is a computational trick
where a high dimensional feature map
can be or the the uh the dot product
between
two high dimensional feature maps can be
compactly represented by
a simple more straightforward function
like this yes question
why does this hold this one
yeah so there is there is uh details of
that in the notes it's you know
it's you know algebra you just work
through it and you can see that these
two are actually exactly the same
right so the i could give you some some
intuitions for example
right so 1 x 1 x 2
till x d and similarly here you have say
z 1 z z1
z2 till zd
you have x1 square z1 square
and so on so if you take the
the dot product between these two you
get 1
1 plus x 1 z 1
plus x 2 z 2 plus 1 till
x d z d
plus x1 square z1 square
and so on and then you can group the
terms and each of those
will correspond to one of them
yeah so the the uh the the kernel
function is
is um is defined such that
the the functional form of the
of the uh of the kernel can always be
rewritten as an in a dot product between
some feature map of x and some feature
map of z
where you apply the same feature map for
both the inputs and then take
a dot product in that higher dimensional
feature space
right and this way an order
d cube operation
was reduced to an order d operation
yes questions
yeah so um the script x is
so first it's important to note that the
script x is the input to the kernel or
the input of the feature map
right so that is not the high
dimensional space script x is not the
high dimensional space where we want to
do the dot product
script x is the space over which we want
our
over which we are trying to learn so
that our examples reside in scriptex
right and the feature map takes
ah something in script
so the feature map maps script x
to rp where p is potentially an infinite
dimensional space
right and the the ah
the claim here is that instead of
performing
inner products in high dimensional
spaces
there would for for for a feature
ah a feature fee
can have a corresponding kernel k where
the kernel function has a more compact
representation
which is equivalent to performing
a dot product in the high dimensional
space
so so the question is how does how does
the kernel reduce the number of
operations
uh the the way it reduces the operation
is
so mathematically we can see that this
representation
and this representation are the same
right but
computationally in this repre in this
representation we require order d
cube operations whereas
to do this this requires order d
operations or the d
operations order d operations you get a
scalar and then you know square q
and sum them up which are negligible
right so
computationally this requires order d
whereas this requires order d cube
this question
feature map yes so the kernel that uh
that
we wrote here is specific to this
feature map exactly
and we're going to uh discuss about you
know kernels in general next
so this is just a motivating example
where um
instead of performing operations in you
know if d is a thousand
instead of doing uh a dot product with
you know two billion dimensional vectors
instead we can do something with just
you know thousand dimensional vectors
which is like a million times faster
right
so now if we replace
the ah the inner product between these
two
feature vectors with the kernel we end
up with
an algorithm for linear regression like
this
right so this is
linear
regression kernelized
the first thing is
pre-compute
a matrix k where
k i j is equal to
k of x i
x j right and
it is common in literature to abuse
notation
and use the same letter k for both the
the matrix of for the kernel function
and also what is called as the kernel
matrix which is
a square symmetric matrix of
all the kernel the kernels evaluated
between every pair of your examples
right and this is equal to
phi of x i
comma v of x
j right so pre compute that
and then do a loop
there for all i in
1 through n
beta i of t plus 1
equals beta i of
t plus alpha times
y i minus
over j equals 1 to n
beta j of
t times k
i j
beta t of k i j yeah
right so
we compute all the all the
all the n square possible inner products
and construct what is called as a kernel
matrix
and once we pre-compute it
even though fees are are in order to
pre-compute it
even though fees might live in like a
billion dimensional vectors
by using the kernel form the
corresponding kernel form for that
feature vector
we will we can compute it
compute each element effectively in just
order order d instead of order d cube
for this kind of a feature map and then
we
iterate over this step where we are
updating
the corresponding coefficients where
beta are called coefficients
from step to step in in the following
way and this is taken directly from
here where we replace this inner product
with k i j of the kernel matrix
and
you can also compactly write this as
beta t plus one equals
beta t plus
alpha times the vector y minus
k beta t
so this is ah these two are equivalent
but instead of doing it for all i
you can perform it in in in one
iteration
in a vectorized format this question
so i'm going to come to that so the
question is uh what if we don't have a
few terms
in this feature map then this is not uh
then this
will not be a the kernel corresponding
to this feature map that is true
and uh we will go into feature maps ah
in a moment right after we wrap up this
example
right so this is for learning
and for prediction time ah
prediction so the we have
h theta of x is equal to
theta transpose
theta transpose phi of x
right and again we expand out theta as
i equals 1 to n
beta i times
phi of
x i transpose
p of x this is
i equals 1 to n
beta i k of
x i comma x where
x is the test example
right
so the ah in in
in case of the linear regression without
feature maps or without kernels we would
have ended up with some
theta vector some high dimensional theta
vector
and this could be potentially infinite
dimensional that is why we use our
our coefficient format to rewrite
theta so this is theta
theta is
we rewrite theta as a linear combination
of our feature vectors where
the corresponding coefficients were
learned in in
through this algorithm right and at
prediction time
we evaluate the kernel between our test
example
and every example in our training set
right multiplied by the corresponding
beta coefficients and this is going to
be our prediction
right so
with this let us make a few observations
any questions on this
so let us make a few observations
so in our observations first we see
that in our training rule
right um
so the training rule was
beta equals beta
plus alpha times y minus
k that's the kernel matrix of
of beta and at test time
where
y hat equals
n k of
psi comma x right in both of these
phi of x
does not appear
right so that is the most important
thing right
we have rewritten our algorithms in such
a way
that the high dimensional feature map
phi of x does not appear either during
training or during testing
and that's the most important thing
because if we have phi of x explicitly
occurring in any of our update rules
then we would have to compute that and
that could be infinite dimensional
right so we got rid of phi of x
completely right that's the most
important observation
the second observation is that
for test time yes question
so the question is
if phi was infinite dimensional then
will the kernel also have an infinite
sum
and the answer is
not always there are many kernels that
we're going to
see next where even though you have
um an infinite dimensionally long
feature vector your kernel can always be
evaluated at
sometimes even constant time right and
we're going to
see a few examples the whole idea is
that
the explicit form representation of the
feature map
can be computationally very expensive
and
there will sometimes be this more
compact
kernelized form where this explicit form
can be computed in a more
efficient way right this question
uh of of this equation
update rule yeah uh so in the update
rule
um so this is just um so k i j
represents the
the uh ijth element of the matrix and
that should be a scalar
and the kernel always computes into a
scalar
the kernel always computes into scalar
right and for beta so beta is a vector
so beta of t
is an r n right
so beta t plus 1 or the the
the jth beta at step t plus 1 is equal
to the old beta
plus alpha against scalar so scalar
scalar times
something y i is a scalar and
k i j are scalars and you are summing
over
some scalar times some scalar so this
the whole thing is a scalar
right so i'm sorry
so j is just the index you're you're
summing over
yeah so beta beta j is a scalar so beta
t
is an rn so beta t subscript j is a
scalar
right so this whole thing is a scalar
scalar minus scalar times a scalar plus
a scalar equals a scalar
right and similarly over here this is a
vector in rn
rn y is an rn
k is n by n beta t is
r n so n by n times r n will give you
n so there is a n vector n vector
difference is an n vector times a scalar
is an n vector plus an n vector equals n
vector
so back to our observations so the first
thing we observed is that we have
eliminated phi of x completely
right that's that's the most important
most important step
the second observation that we make is
to make a prediction we need to remember
all our test examples
right so for prediction
we need training examples
to be stored
in memory
right and this is probably the most
distinctive feature from linear
regression that we've seen
in linear regression we started with a
training
training set with x's and y's
we learnt the theta vector by performing
ah say the normal equations or
gradient descent and once we obtained
the theta vector
we could discard our entire training set
and only carry forward
theta the theta vector from that point
on and to perform
a prediction on a new example all you
needed was the theta vector you didn't
need the training sets anymore
right but with kernel methods that's not
true anymore
right by giving up the phi of x
representation
uh explicitly x representation we've
also given up the possibility of having
a theta vector that we could that alone
we could carry forward
right in place of that we need to
remember all our
training examples
and i missed a beta i here we
um we need to remember all our training
examples
and when we get a new test example we
evaluate the kernel
with every training example and take a
linear combination
of those kernel outputs
weighted by the uh the beta vector that
we learned
right so training examples must be
carried forward
as is into test time with kernel methods
any questions on this
and to to kind of better understand
how what was happening so let's assume
that
in linear regression we were given a
matrix
let's so this was the design matrix x
where each row is an example
let us call this x
x 1 till x
n
and we had y
right and in linear regression we wanted
to learn a theta vector
right so if
x was in r d
theta was also in rd
right and when we started gradient
descent we start with some theta 0
and then perform a gradient update and
get a theta 1
right and then perform an update and get
theta 2 and so on until the theta
vectors converge
right but with kernel methods
we observe the fact that the thetas were
always
a linear combination of our x vectors
right that's that's the observation that
we made that theta ah
that theta at any any step in gradient
descent could always be represented as
some linear combination of our vectors
right and we instead
stored
beta0 where we had one beta for example
right and each theta so
say this was ah beta0
and using our our
algorithm over here we we would get ah
beta1
right then we get
beta 2 and so on where each of the betas
were in
r n whereas theta was in r d
right thetas had one
component per feature
betas have one component for example
right and every beta vector has a
corresponding theta vector
where theta vector is so
theta of
t is equal to sum
over i equals one to n
beta of t i
x of i right
and this holds true
even if we
so we use this fact to
to kind of extend our
x into a
high dimension so supposing you know we
map this
into phi of x which is in
r p right and now what used to be a d
dimensional vector is now a p
dimensional
vector right and this
we can we could we could have mapped x
in uh we mapped x into some phi of x
and this p of x could have been
infinitely infinite dimensionally wide
right and no matter how big our feature
vectors are the beta vectors are going
to be
fixed length one for example
and this is what allows us to
scale in terms of features
and we just remember the corresponding
beta vectors by which we weight our
examples
any any questions on this
yes question
yeah so the question is is it really
practical to remember all
all our training examples into test time
and the answer is
in general yes you need to do that and
that makes kernel methods not very
scalable as you get lots and lots of
data
which is why you know in in practice you
see when you have lots and lots of data
you see methods like
neural networks and deep learning take
over because they don't have this
limitation
that you need to remember all your
examples all your training examples
but at the same time there are
algorithms that we are going to see
in fact later today called the support
vector machine where
the support vector machine will result
in beta vectors that are very sparse
which means most of them are zeros
so you just need to remember a few of
your examples right um
and those are called like your support
vectors uh we we will
uh go into the support vector next but
in general
um your beta vectors can be dense which
means you need to remember
all your training examples all the way
to test time and in fact that
is a big obstacle for you know scaling
your algorithms to big data sets and
that does come into
come into play uh if you want to use
kernel methods that's right
yeah good question
any other questions so let's look at
some properties of kernels
right so what we saw so far was a way
was was an example of an algorithm which
was linear regression
that we kernelized right and linear
regression is just
one algorithm that you can colonize you
can kernelize
a lot of algorithms and and
in fact you can follow the same steps
and you can even kernelize generalized
linear models which means you know
logistic regression for sound regression
they can also be kernelized
where you
you replace this with some g function
right
and ah you know by by having a g
function for example
you know the sigmoid function of the
logistic function and following the same
recipe you
we can kernelize any generalized linear
model
algorithm as well and there are lots of
other algorithms that can also be
kernelized
and in fact you know the question of our
kernel methods for
classification or regression you know
wrong question you know you can you can
kernelize lots of different kinds of
algorithms our kernel
kernel methods for discriminative or
generative models
uh the answer is they can work for both
you can kinda lies uh generative models
you can kernelize
discriminative models or kernel methods
for supervised learning or unsupervised
learning
they can work for both you know you can
kernelize supervised learning algorithms
you can
uh kernelize uh unsupervised learning
algorithms so kernel
this uh kernelization or what what's
called as a kernel trick
is a very general technique that can be
applied in lots of different places
and let us look at a few properties of
kernels
so
kernel examples so
for example example a
k of x comma z
equals x transpose
v square are
and this has the corresponding
phi of x equals
x 1 x 2 x 1 x 1
x 1 x 2
x d x d
if x is in r d
right so this is one example in fact we
saw a more general example of
ah previously similarly you can have
example b ah i'm just i'm just writing
out a few examples that are in your
notes
um x comma z
equals x transpose
z plus c square so take the dot product
add a constant and then square it
that can also be ah that is also a
kernel
which corresponds to a feature vector
that looks like this
v of x equals
x 1 square x 1 x 2
and then you have square root of
2 c times x 1
square root of 2 c times x 2 and so on
and um
it might not be obvious ah at first you
know
that looking at this form
it's not directly obvious whether you
can represent this
as a dot product between two feature
vectors
but if you work through it you can come
up with a feature representation
and similarly when you when you're given
a feature representation
it's not always obvious whether you can
actually you know save some computation
by coming up with a more
uh compact representation and in fact
for many years
this was like an active area of research
where you know researchers would come up
with new kernels which are you know
which had nice properties and
and so forth and
uh also one would um imagine that
the the order in which we presented
kernels was that first we
uh first we came up with a feature
vector
and and then we saw that the feature
vector could have
been represented as a more compact
kernel
but in practice the way things go
go about in research in reality is that
people
come up with a function k equals
you know some form you know k of x comma
z
equals something that involves x and z
and what not
and then try to you know convince
themselves that you can come up with
some feature vector for it
in in in um in reality people come up
with functions and try to prove that
it's a kernel rather than
starting with a feature map and and see
if you know there's a kernel
corresponding to it
right and kernels can also be seen as
similarity metrics was there a question
yes question
so this x1 x1 x1 x2 x1 x3 and so on then
x2 x1 x2 x2 x2 x3
so this is a feature map a feature map
can work only on one input
right so it is important to note that
when we write
k of x comma z equals
phi of x transpose phi of z
the fee the feature map
must only involve terms from one input
so ah
so that would be you know x 1 z 1
plus x 2 z 2
and so on whole square right and this
would be
x 1 square
z1 square plus x2 square
z2 square plus cross terms right
and this is x1 x1 and with phi of c
there are going to be a z1 z1 and when
you do the dot product you're going to
get this term
right so kernels can be seen as
similarity matrix
which means if you can um so it
so kernels are generally constructed
such that similar examples
evaluate to a higher value in the kernel
and
you know dissimilar examples evaluate to
a small value in the kernel
right and this idea of using kernels as
similarity metrics will will actually
show up in
in uh one of the future topics that
we're going to cover called gaussian
processes right gaussian processes
is a kernel method uh algorithm and over
there
ah kernel acting as a similarity metric
is kind of highlighted
i'm sorry this one
so this is x transpose z plus c
some constant c whole square and that c
shows up over here sorry
right um so
can be seen as a similarity matrix and
[Music]
we want k of x comma
z to be high
for
similar x z and we wanted to be low
for not similar
x comma c right and
and this should be kind of this this
might be
obvious ah the reason why
we we ah we say this is because
k of
x comma z is equal to phi of
x transpose phi of z
and we've seen that for similarly
oriented vectors
phi x and v z they're the dot product
will be high if
they are oriented somewhat similarly
which means they are
you know similar examples and similar
you know the dot product between
you know opposite vectors pointing
opposite is going to be
negative uh which means if they're not
similar
the kernel will will evaluate them to ah
be a smaller value
and in fact there is also this kernel
which is very
popular called k of
x comma z equal to
exponent of minus
x minus z square over
2 sigma square so this kernel
is also called the gaussian kernel
because it it looks
uh it looks like you know the gaussian
pdf
subject to you know um if you ignore the
normalizing constant
this is it is also called the squared
exponential kernel
because you square it and you
exponentiate it
and the idea here is that if x and z are
very
close or similar x minus z will be 0
and exponent of 0 is just 1. but if x
and z are
far apart then x minus z will be a big
value
and the square of that will be also be a
big value and
exponent of a negative big value is is
close to zero
right so for similar examples the
gaussian kernel will evaluate to
closer to one and for dissimilar
examples it will evaluate close to zero
and this kernel in particular
has if you expand it which is i would
say beyond the scope of our course
if you were to expand this kernel into a
feature vector
then you will see that there are the
gaussian kernel
has an infinite dimensional feature
vector
but that is beyond scope of this course
this question
yeah the the the the question is uh is
is there is there any relation between
this and locally weighted
um regression yes there are connections
but we did not cover
locally weighted regression so i will
not go into it in the lecture but yes
there are there are some connections yes
so now the question is given a
kernel function k
how do we know or given a function k
what makes it a kernel how do we know
that a function k is a kernel right
so necessary conditions
for k to be
a kernel right
so first of all k
should be symmetric
which means k of x comma
z should be equal to k of z comma
x
and then
for a given collection of examples
say x 1 through
x
call it m now some collection of
examples that this need not be your
training set it could be
any collection of m examples
the kernel matrix k i j
equals k of
x i comma
x j where the collection of
examples could be anything you know
completely unrelated to your
training set even this kernel matrix k
is symmetric
and positive symmetra
and the reason why it's it should be
positive semi definite is
is pretty easy to see so consider some
other vector z
and z transpose k z
can be written as sum over i
sum over j z
i k i j z j
and this you know if you do some steps
you will see that
this is equal to sum over k where k is
the
is the is the number of features in this
feature vector
so we show that z transpose k z is
greater than
equal to zero for any z right
so if a kernel
so the definition of a kernel as a
reminder
definition of a kernel corresponding to
some feature vector phi
is v of x
transpose p of z this is the
mathematical definition
right but in general this could be any
function
k that evaluates to the same value
as the explicit dot product
and that's the definition of a kernel
that it has
a feature representation like this and
in order for a kernel in order for any
function k to be a kernel
these are the necessary conditions for
it
and the second necessary condition
of ah so this is the symmetric
and this is on you know the psd
condition
on a set of examples there is a theorem
called
mercer's theorem
which says this necessary condition
is also a sufficient condition for k to
be a kernel
right so the mercer's theorem says ah
let k
in this case we're going to just limit
ourselves to r d
to r be given
so this is some function some function
then
for k to
be a kernel
it is necessary
and sufficient
for
x1 through
xm
the corresponding
kernel matrix
k i j equals k of
x i x j
is positive semi definite and symmetric
right so ah mercer's theorems
tells us that a function k
for it to be a kernel then for any
collection of input examples the
corresponding kernel matrix
will be symmetric and positive semi
definite
and and if this property holds
for ah for for any set of examples if
the corresponding kernel matrix is
positive and semi definite then k must
be a kernel so it goes both ways
and the proof of this theorem is is
beyond the scope of our course
but we can still get some intuitions on
this right
so as as as a reminder
a few lectures ago we we saw this kind
of relation between linear algebra and
function analysis right in that um
vectors are like functions
right and matrices
matrix is like operators
or
or functions with two inputs also
functions with say x and y right
so the kernel function k
right which which for which we saw you
know many compact
compact representations imagine this
kernel to be an
infinite dimensional matrix right
it extends to infinity in in in all
directions
right and k of s
x comma z is you know
evaluates to some value right where on
one
one axis consider the xth row
and on the other axis consider the z
column
x throw z column
right imagine this to be a two input
function
and in this case um i'm drawing the
horizontal and vertical
axis as as linear but you know think of
this as some
abstract access so each each column
corresponds to z which could actually be
a vector itself
right here it appears as though um z
axis is is real valued but you know uh
z is is uh think of each of the axis as
some abstract axes right so k of
x comma z is going to give you evaluate
to some value
and if you have a collection um x1
through x
m then evaluating say k of
x 1 x 2 would be here k of x 1
x 3 would be here k of x 1 x 3 would be
here so
and similarly k of x 2 x 1 and so on
right and you are going to extract these
evaluations
right into a kernel matrix
where each row belongs to x one
x two and so on x m and similarly
x one x m
right and we also know that k
can be represented as the um
the feature as as the um
as the inner product between two
features which means
k is in some way a positive definite
kernel
or a positive definite function and what
it means is that
if you take some bunch of examples which
means you choose a few axes
and extract the values into a matrix
this matrix is always positive semi
definite
and it says if and only if which means
if any such matrix for any such you know
collection of examples if you extract
the evaluations you get a positive semi
definite matrix
and if that holds true for any positive
semi definite matrix then
k is a valid kernel which means it's a
positive definite function
and that is basically a way of saying um
any sub matrix of a positive semi
different matrix
is also positive semi different
right so mercer's kernel mercer's
theorem is basically a way of saying
ah a sub matrix of any positive definite
matrix is also positive definite
and that is just some intuition for for
ah what ah versus kernels
telling us
so ah that's about it in terms of
properties of kernels
to ah as i said in in order to prove
that a function is a kernel you have two
options
to prove k is kernel
just to summarize this one you know
construct phi
such that k is equal to
phi transpose phi
right or
two for use mercer's theorem
versus theorem which means for any
collection
x 1 through x
m k i j
equals k of
x i x j
is positive summer right
in fact there is also
a 3 which generally is it's very hard to
to prove that the double integral of
for any f for all f
the double integral of f of x
k of x x prime
f of x prime d x
d x prime is greater than or equal to 0.
so this is basically saying this
infinite dimensional matrix
is positive semi definite and
this is saying um you know
a sub matrix is positive ah semi
definite and mercer's theorem basically
tells us that
this will hold true for any sub matrix
you know it's basically a statement uh
saying any sub matrix of possibly
definite is also positive
yes
yeah this is just the quadratic form
written in function analysis
in functional notation yeah
all right so that's it about kernels so
we saw kernels for
linear regression and now we're going to
spend
a little little bit of time to see how
they get used in
support vector machines so
support vector machines we are not going
to cover support vector machines in
detail in this class
mostly because
once upon a time support vector machines
like you know 10 years ago was
a super hot topic and
there is shrinking amount of interest
in support vector machines but it is
still interesting to
to see how support vector machines are
formulated and
how kernels play a role there
right so support vector machines
so support vector machines is
a discriminative
classification
[Music]
algorithm and the idea of support vector
machines is
if you have some examples x1 you know
xd let's say you have a few
examples here and a few
[Music]
examples here right now how do we come
up with a separating hyperplane
right by just looking at this there are
so many possible hyperplanes that we can
come up with for example
this could be a separating hyperplane
right there are so many
and infinitely many possible separating
hyper planes that that we could come up
with
and the question is you know what should
be
the ideal separating hyper plane that um
that we that we can come up with given a
data set like this that's ah separable
and for that the answer uses this
concept called a margin
right so the margin is
it basically tells us
right so the margin um you can think of
the margin as
y i
right before before we get into there
some notational changes from before
why i
for this lecture alone think of it as
being in
plus 1 or minus 1 instead of 1 and 0
just because it's going to make the
notation a little simpler you know but
this is just a superficial change there
is
you know nothing fundamentally changes
we are just using different numbers to
indicate different classes
and the parameters
will be w and b
where w is in rd
and b is in
r and our examples x are also in rd
and we make predictions with w transpose
x plus b what this basically means is
we assume we are not loading the
intercept term x naught equal to 1
into our examples and we are going to
have an explicit
separately written out parameter called
b in place of
having an intercept term right so the
margin
is defined as y i times
w transpose
x i plus b right
now the the ah
the idea is
again very similar to ah logistic
regression
where our predicted value w transpose x
plus b
we want it to be greater than 0
for y equals plus 1 and we want it to be
less than 0
for y equals minus 1. so let's suppose
this is
y equals plus 1 class and this is y
equals minus 1 class
right we want y i
times w
uh w transpose x plus b to be greater
than zero for
y equals one no we want w transpose
x to be greater than zero for y equals 1
and
w transpose x to be less than 0 for y
equals minus 1
which means y i times w transpose x plus
b
should always be greater than 0 for both
y equals 1 and y equals minus 1
right so what we desire
is margin
to be large
right and the the definition of the
margin is taking into account
that uh for some of the examples uh w
transpose x plus b will be greater than
zero and for some it is
less than zero and for the cases when it
is supposed to be less than zero we
multiply it by
minus one so the margin you know after
multiply like
minus one has to be large no matter what
the example is
right and the idea of support vector
machine is
to calculate the margin
for from the given
given a hyperplane calculate the margin
with respect to all the examples and
maximize the smallest margin
right that's the that's the idea of of
the support vector machine
which means in general now for example
ah for this
separating hyper plane the smallest
margin is here
right and for this hyperplane
the smallest margin is here
the smallest margin is probably here
right and we want to choose the hyper
plane
that gives us the largest
small margin right so calculate the
smallest margin
and choose the hyper plane for which the
smallest margin is the largest
right and that's the intuition behind a
support vector machine
right now the ah one thing that you can
that you can observe is that
if we are able to find some hyper plane
for which we are able to correctly
classify all the examples
if you are able to find one such w and b
that correctly classifies all the
examples
then with this definition of a margin
we can kind of fool the system
by choosing scaled versions of w
and b so for example in place of
w if we have 2w and in place of of
b we have 2b then the margin by this
definition effectively doubles
right so if we are seeking a separating
hyperplane
where this into this geometric notion of
margin
is largest in some sense where the
smallest geometric margin
is is is the largest then this
definition
of margin my is is vulnerable
for being gamed you can always scale up
your w's and b's
and increase your margin even more
though it does not change your
separating hyperplane in any way right
and that is why
so this is also called as functional
margin
so the support vector machine is
an algorithm that tries to maximize the
geometric margin which means the
actual geometric distance between the
the
separating hyperplane and the examples
right this is not the
geometric distance between x and the
hyperplane
right because this you can you can you
can use 2w
and 2b and
so if w transpose x plus b
equals 0 this corresponds to the
separating hyper plane
you can scale your w's and b's with any
scalar
and still have the same separating
hybrid plane
but this definition of margin
would result in a larger value you would
get a larger functional margin
for the same separating hyperplane right
and the support vector machine
addresses this this specific
ah problem and we are only going to look
at the
the problem formulation and not actually
solve it
for this course so the support vector
machine
so in support vector machine we seek
a value of w and b such that
w and b gives us the ideal margin and
this is the wrong
wrong objective to maximize because this
objective is vulnerable to being scaled
and being fooled right
so the objective instead that support
vector machines uses
is this so
minimize with respect to w and b
i equals 1 to n
max
0 comma 1 minus
y i
times w transpose
x i plus b
plus one over c
w squared
so what is what is happening here so we
have a
1 minus y i
times w transpose x plus b
and we have a max between this and 0
right
this term over here is
commonly called as the hinge loss
you will see why it is called that way
or it is also called
sometimes the svm loss
you see this term in um many places
so what this means is you know if you
want to think of this
as your margin you know this
is still the function margin right let
us call this
equal to gamma of i
right and if this is
gamma then
one the the hinge
loss looks like this
right so this whole term is called the
hinge loss
is called the hinge loss and it looks
like this
why why does it look like this so if
for all values where the margin
is
margin does not include the 1 minus so
this is the margin
so whenever the margin is bigger than 1
then the right hand term after the comma
is going to be less than 0
so for all values when the margin is
bigger than 1 the right time
right hand the the second the second
term will be
less than zero and the max between zero
and the negative number will be zero
and so the hinge loss for any value of
of of gamma or margin
bigger than one the hinge loss is always
zero
and for all values where the hinge loss
is
evaluates to something less than one
so for example if the hinge loss
evaluates to
let us say zero point one
then this is going to be between max of
and 1 minus 0.1 that's max of 0 and 0.9
so when gamma is 0.1
the loss is going to be 0.9 right and
as as you keep decreasing gamma further
the hinge loss is going to be more and
more
right so what this what this is
basically telling us
is learn w and b
such that w transpose x plus b
is at least plus one we want it to be
just greater than zero for y equals plus
one
but the loss is instead telling actually
we are not satisfied if it is just
bigger than 0 but actually make it
bigger than 1
right go further and
because we know that um
because we know that this
functional margin now this functional
margin
is vulnerable to this kind of scaling
where you know the algorithm can you
know once once the algorithm
finds ah finds a w and b such that
w transpose x plus b is is 0.1
it could just scale up w and b further
to just increase
your the the margin to go greater than
one
and in order to safeguard against that
kind of a scaling
we also penalize the norm of w which
means you can't just
increase the value of w by by scaling it
larger
and thereby increasing the functional
margin you actually need to
you know find a well suited
well suited w and b such that you know
there is there is
such that they are actually far away
from the examples
right and this formulation can be
rewritten as
so this optimization problem can be
min psi
w b half
w square plus c times
sum over i equals 1 to
n c
i such
that y i
times w transpose
x i plus b
is greater than equal to 1 minus
the c i for all
i n 1 1 through n
and c i is greater than equal to
0 i equals 1
to n now this formulation
it looks different from this but it
but the two are are are actually
equivalent
in the sense the optimal solution you
get for w and b
from this problem is the same as the w
and b you would get from this problem
and the reason why
we don't want this form to be solved
directly is because
this max operator is not differentiable
right
whereas this is what is also called as a
convex problem
where the loss is convex the thing that
you want to minimize and the constraints
are convex
right and once you have a problem um
written out in this form where the
objective and the constraints are all
convex then there are lots of solvers
that can just solve this for you
right and
the way the another
another topic in convex optimization is
that
for every such convex problem there is
an equivalent
dual problem right so this is also
called think of this as the
primal convex problem
correspondingly there is a dual
convex problem
and the dual convex problem looks
something like this
max over alpha
so to be clear you don't need to know
convex optimization for this course and
you don't need to know how to derive
this
you just need to have the intuitions of
how
the svm is trying to optimize the
geometric margin and whereas
this is just the functional margin the
functional margin can be fooled by just
scaling w's and b
so instead svm
includes this penalty term to to save
itself from getting fooled
and that's equivalent to this convex
problem
and that is equivalent to this dual
convex problem this question
good question why don't we penalize b
there are good reasons why you don't
want to penalize b because
if you penalize b you're constraining
your separating hyper plane to be close
to the origin
right but that that there's no value in
doing that
you want you want to give your algorithm
freedom to place it
however far from the origin as necessary
depending on the data
so so uh um i would say i would
encourage you to go through the notes
and you can see why
you know penalizing b is a wrong idea uh
if you know if you're still interested
but the intuition to have there is that
by penalizing b you're
restricting the algorithm to have a
hyper plane that's close to zero
and that's you know that seems pretty
arbitrary
so so the thing is w and b are kind of
work differently so b
tells you how far apart you can be from
the origin and
you don't want any kind of constraint
over there
right um so there is an equivalent dual
problem alpha i
minus half
y i
this is a double sum over i j y i
y j
alpha i alpha j and inner product
between
x i
x j such that
0 less than equal to alpha i less than
equal to c
and sum over y equals one to n
alpha i y i equals
zero anyways so
if if your if you know convex analysis
uh if you know convex optimization
this problem can be can be rewritten
in this form but you don't need to know
how how you go from here to here for
this course
right but once you write it in this this
form you see that
we end up with uh
we end up with the term where we are
doing taking a dot product between
pairs of examples and we are doing that
across all pairs right
over here we were explicitly trying to
learn
w and b right and and to kind of
draw the similarity between linear
regression this is like trying to find
the theta vector
but in the dual form we are trying to
find
alpha a collection of coefficients
alphas where each alpha
is the weight you apply to each example
and that was very similar to
the per example betas that we saw in
linear regression
so in the in the dual problem we are
trying to find the coefficients with
which we weigh
weight examples and we can represent the
algorithm
completely in terms of in terms of a dot
product between examples
right and here you can replace this dot
product with a feature map and
you can replace that dot product between
features with a kernel and that's how
kernels come into picture
in support vector machines using the
dual formulation
right and the one unique property
i would say unique property or one nice
property
of support vector machines is that once
you solve this problem
the set of alphas that you that you
obtain as as
as a result of this optimization problem
will be sparse
which means only a small
number of alpha i's will be non-zero but
most of the alpha i's will be zero
right and that means that those set of
examples
for which the alpha i's were non-zeros
are called the support vectors
and intuitively those will be the
those examples that are nearest to the
separating hyperplane
all right uh i think we're over time and
ah
that's pretty much all we wanted to
cover about support vector machines the
the main idea that you need to remember
about support vector machines for this
course
is this this idea of functional margin
versus geometric margin
and that it's possible to write the svm
in this dual convex
problem as this dual convex problem and
that's going to result in coefficients
that are sparse right that's that's the
extent to which
we need to know about svms for this
course